-Welcome back.
We're here with Ricky Gervais.
I feel bad.
I didn't ask after your health.
Have you managed to make it
through these last two years
without falling ill?
-Yeah. Well, yeah.
I mean, well --
I wouldn't say I'm healthy,
but I haven't caught COVID.
I mean,
I'm 20 pounds overweight.
I'm 60. I'm losing my hair.
I'm fat. I've got a bunion.
I've got bad knees.
I've got a bad back.
Back goes every now and again.
I'm a -- I'm a slob.
I -- It's because
I eat and drink too much.
I'm drunk now.
Because I'm in England.
And I don't mean
because of the time zone.
I mean it's compulsory.
If you're in England,
you've got to be drunk.
It's one of the rules, right?
So -- But, yeah,
I haven't caught COVID, no.
Maybe I have.
I always wake up sort of sweaty
and anxious and feeling [bleep],
so I might have COVID.
I don't know. But --
[ Laughs ] I wouldn't know.
I wouldn't --
In fact, all the way through
the first year,
every time I woke up,
I thought I had COVID.
But then I'd wake up,
if I've got a sore throat,
I'd go, "Jane, it's cancer."
And she goes, "No, it's not.
Go to the doctor."
And I'd go, "Don't say that."
So I google it.
And then the first five,
they go, "Oh, it's nothing."
And then I google too much,
and it goes -- this one's rare
and it's terminal.
And I go, "I've got that one."
But apart from that, I'm --
Yeah, I'm well.
-Yeah, good.
-I'm in really good shape.
Mentally.
-Do you think maybe all
the sort of awards behind you
created, like,
a natural immunity to it?
-Maybe.
It plays havoc with the Wi-Fi.
Yeah, I'm in
Meryl Streep's house.
Um, yeah.
I didn't place them there.
They're there all the time.
This is in my study.
It's not like I put them out.
I'm on set when I put out all --
"Jane, get all the awards,
put them all behind me!"
-While we're talking
about awards, you sort of --
the Hollywood Foreign Press.
The Golden Globes happened
a couple of weeks ago
just online.
It was a Twitter feed.
This is how far
the Golden Globes have fallen.
I hosted it once. You hosted it
five times, very famously.
I think you are the person
most associated with that.
Are you surprised
at where this has sort of led?
-Basically you're blaming me.
You're trying to blame me,
aren't you?
-I only did it once, and
you did it, like, five times.
-"I did it once.
And it was fine. It kept going.
He did it five times.
It's done."
Well, I wouldn't
watch it anyway.
The only time I've ever watched
an awards show, I'm at.
I'm either winning or losing
an award or presenting it.
I loved it, though.
I thought it was great.
I did it five times
over ten years.
And it's funny because
the first time I did it,
I could feel particularly the
sort of Hollywood press, right?
They were going, "Who is this?
Who this is fat annoying Brit?"
How dare he --
How dare he make fun
of the most important people
in the world," right?
Over ten years, I kept going.
I kept doing the same thing.
But the world changed.
And by the last one,
the public were going,
"Yeah, give it to 'em.
We're sick of celebrities.
We hate them.
We're tired of being lectured,
telling us to recycle
when they're going
on a private jet."
So I think ordinary people
were suddenly just --
They sort of turned
a little bit.
They didn't --
They were sick of being told
what to do by rich people.
So I think I hit a lucky streak
on the last one.
But it was fun. It was just fun.
It's not what I do,
but it was fun.
-You do -- You have started
doing stand-up again.
You have a new special
coming out on Netflix.
Was this a hour,
or however long it is,
that you'd been working on
before the pandemic?
-Yeah, I did --
I did lots of gigs
and then just --
It just stopped
in sort of like --
February. Was it 2020?
And, yeah, I had, like,
over half still to go.
And it was amazing.
Because people kept their
tickets for like two years.
Which -- And then
I managed to finish it
between sort of
June and Christmas.
And it was amazing.
Because the atmosphere
was electric.
I was so happy
to be back to normal.
I really am appreciating
my audience
more now than I ever did.
I really -- It really hit me.
Almost on an emotional level.
Because you think, you know,
that they're paying
hard-earned cash and
they've got to find a babysitter
and a parking space.
And I better have
something to say.
But I really, really love it.
I can't wait to start again.
And I've recorded the special.
But now Netflix got to
translate it into 160 languages.
I didn't know
there were 160 languages,
but apparently there are,
and that will be out in spring.
But I'll be on a new one.
I can't wait to get back.
I think it's my favorite thing
I do now, stand-up.
-Do you worry about that lead
time after you record a special
and before it comes out
that any of the jokes will age?
-Yeah. Lots of things,
I think, you know --
Luckily, my set list is like,
you know, AIDS, famine, Hitler.
And they're evergreen.
[ Laughter ]
They -- [ Laughs ]
They age really well.
-So, like, the worst thing
that would happen to you
right now would be, like,
new Hitler news.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah!
Exactly. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-If anything happened
where people are like,
"Oh, I'm going to
reconsider Hitler."
-Yeah, exactly, yeah.
Find out something.
"Oh, no. That ruins everything."
I do think that, though.
I do think that.
Like --
If Boris Johnson's not around.
I do one joke
about Boris Johnson,
and if he's not around, I go,
"Oh, no, that ruins that joke."
-I can't thank you enough
for being here, Ricky.
I really do hope next time
you're in New York City with us.
Ricky Gervais. All three
seasons of "After Life"
are currently streaming
on Netflix.